Were there any sort of metrics that
you measured that you thought were
initially important but weren't,
they were really just vanity metrics?
>> Yeah.
We measured day 1 retention rate pretty
intensely, and we tried to do everything
right to get the day 1 retention rate,
but we found out that day 1 to day 7
retention rate drop-off was not really
important.
We found that day 7 to day 14 drop-off
rate was more important than that.
So we just discarded thinking about
day 1 retention rate after some time.
>> And were there any other
metrics that came up or
that any other thing that you wanted
to dig into more that you weren't
initially sure whether this was going to
be a good metric for the company?
>> We did not, we always wanted to
find out how many invites were sent,
but we did not know the number of,
we were not really in a position
to differentiate between invites
sent by a new user as well as invites
sent by an already existing user.
So invites sent by an already existing
user were more critical, more important
for us, which we did not think they
were important in the beginning.
But later we found out that these two,
instead of invite,
these two set of user base
was completely different.
They affected differently
on our product.
>> Yeah.